today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i put the link right below
this video
so there's been a building sort of
chorus of people both on the trumpian
right and also some on the ante biden
left who have just been insisting that
joe biden
can't possibly hold it together in an
interview
he can't possibly hold it together under
questioning from reporters
and we had finally some examples that we
can look at joe biden was interviewed on
abc news over the weekend alongside his
running mate kamala harris this was
the first joint interview that they did
i believe
and the interview was remarkable in how
unremarkable
it was from the standpoint of the
hysteria and the hyperbole and the
craziness that we've become used to
under donald trump
it was just like a boring political
interview joe biden answered questions
and he answered follow-up questions and
he sounded like a politician for better
or worse
and was completely coherent like this
would not normally be news
but it's news when you have people on
both sides
anticipating that joe biden would
devolve
into a stuttering yes he has an actual
stutter
incoherent mess unable to make any point
whatsoever and in fact
i enjoyed the interview not so much
because i just agree with every policy
decision that is being made by this
platform the biden harris platform
but because it was just normal
and we've been hoping for normal for so
long so let's look at some clips here is
joe biden saying
he would do a national shutdown
or recommend one if public health
officials
said it was the right idea for dealing
with coronavirus remember
it's ultimately up to governors what the
president can do is
recommend and say hey guys let's all do
this
and remember that we still have a raging
pandemic
over 180 000 deaths as donald trump
continues to insist we've done
and are doing really well with the virus
here is joe biden
sworn in come january and we have
coronavirus
and the flu combining which many
scientists have said is a real
possibility
would you be prepared to shut this
country down again
i would be prepared to do whatever it
takes to save lives because we cannot
get the country moving
until we control the virus that is the
fundamental flaw this administration's
thinking to begin with
in order to keep the country running and
moving and the economy growing
and people employed you have to fix the
virus you have to deal with the virus
so if the scientists say shut it down i
would shut it down
i would listen to the scientist now
immediately you had people come out and
say oh my god what a socialist
authoritarian
he wants no country he wants no economy
he wants no businesses
come on guys come on haven't we learned
enough at this point haven't we seen
what happened in other countries
versus in the united states when people
wore masks and they took social
distancing seriously
and when you have to shut down sectors
of the economy temporarily you do it but
then you're able to reopen
biden is not saying any if you're
shocked at what biden's saying
then then essentially you're saying the
whole world handled it incorrectly we
we handled it correctly and we have one
of the highest per capita death rates in
the world
biden is just being sensible this is a
medical situation
just a candidate recognizing that
distinguishes them from donald trump
we have to defer to public health and
medical officials that's it
that's what we need in this country and
people are going crazy about
authoritarian joe biden now on top of
that
had we done a two-month coordinated
shutdown meaning
essential businesses only everybody
wears masks
no school back in april or may
we never would have gotten to where we
are today
which is in an emergency situation with
one of the
worst coronavirus responses in the world
people are reacting to biden like he's
the outlier biden is just saying
let's do what the rest of the world
figured out months ago no more no less
then joe biden is asked because
again trump has been criticizing biden
for being in his basement
joe biden was asked can you win a
presidential election from your house
take a look
i understand the restrictions of covid
and campaigning in this time but can you
win a presidential election
from home we will we're going to follow
the science
what the scientists tell us we've been
able to travel places when we've been
able to do it in a way that we don't
cause the congregation of large numbers
of people
look what happens what's happened with
his his
events people die people get together
they don't wear masks they end up
getting covered they end up dying
so when you hear the president say this
guy's afraid to leave his basement
guess what i have left my basement and
but here
in the meantime 500 million people have
watched what i've done out of my
basement
and guess what people are listening
people are listening
it's about being responsible i really
think that this is creating controversy
where there is no controversy here and
what's going to be really interesting is
for three and a half years we've had
this narrative from trump
that the fake news media is all against
them all the media is against them
except fox news
and even fox news sometimes is against
them so you've got to go to oan
to find fair media what a lot of people
have forgotten
i have not forgotten it is that the myth
of the liberal media is a myth
this is a corporatist media with a
penchant
for salaciousness and controversy and
right away
they are taking hook line and sinker
every narrative set by trump
here they're asking about biden in his
basement guys there's a pandemic biden's
being responsible that's it
okay and then they continue to take
debate the bait corporate media does
by asking biden about the attacks donald
trump has been making against biden on
his cognitive fitness now
i happen to think it's fair when you
have candidates
that are in their 70s uh trump
now mid 70s biden closer to 80.
it's totally reasonable to ask about
cognitive fitness
but what's fascinating here is that
corporate supposedly fake news
left-leaning corporate media
they're taking trump's bait on every one
of these issues biden in the basement
and now biden's cognitive fitness
i want to turn to the blistering attacks
we've seen from president trump just
this week alone
on your mental fitness whether you're up
for the job
his campaign has called you diminished
and i'm curious how you'd respond to
that
watch me mr president watch me
look at us both what we say what we do
what we control what we know
what kind of shape we're in come on look
i think it's a legitimate question to
ask anybody over 70 years old whether or
not
they're fit and whether they're ready
but i just
only thing i can say the american people
it's a legitimate question to ask
anybody watch me let's put the attacks
aside then the american people remember
ronald reagan was 77 when he left office
you would be 78
entering office and you have said
yourself that you
are a transition candidate does that
mean a one-term president what is that
no it doesn't mean so you're leaving
open the possibility you'll serve eight
years
absolutely okay so joe biden handling it
perfectly perfectly well and
i do think much like before the bernie
biden debate you had all these people
expecting oh my god
if biden's up against bernie one on one
biden's gonna collapse
and of course he didn't and he went on
to win the primary they were
disappointed
and i think they're going to be
disappointed again in debates against
trump if they happen
i don't expect any kind of collapse
from joe biden biden also was
interviewed by abc's robin roberts asked
about choosing kamala harris and again
this is not a particularly newsworthy
clip it's just notable
that joe biden is normal he's able to
articulate
why he selected kamala harris uh he's
able to speak in complete compound
sentences
we've just become unaccustomed to it
take a look there's a connection there
that i'm going to talk
more about where it comes to bow and and
other aspects
of family you eluded mr vice president
about the fact that you made it clear
early on that you were going to select a
woman to be
your running mate you select a woman of
color
did you do that to rally your base did
you feel
pressure to select a black woman no i
didn't feel pressured to select a black
woman but i
what i do think and i've said it before
and you've heard me say it i probably
said it on your show with you is that
the government should look like the
people
look like the country 51 percent of the
people in this country are women
that that old expression goes women hold
up half the sky
and in order to be able to succeed
you've got to be
dealt in across the board and no matter
what you say
you cannot i cannot understand and
fully appreciate what it means to walk
in her shoes to be
an african-american woman with an indian
american background
a child of immigrants she can't assume
exactly what it's like to walk in my
shoes
what we do know is we have the same
value set and
and i really mean that and so it was it
was
it was easy for me it was an easy
decision to make although there are
enormous number
of really qualified women i spoke to
every single woman
that was on the list before and
as i the day i made the choice before
anything was announced i called every
single one of them
so what was the tipping point the
tipping point was i was
it was there were several things but it
just seemed to fit
the closest and the best i thought i
understood
and i think i understand her where she
comes from
what her instincts are her her character
i watched her take on the big banks i
watched her take on the gun lobby i
watched her
the way she was a prosecutor i watched
her as a united states senator
isn't this so weird that joe biden just
answers questions
and stays on topic and doesn't ramble
and again uses compound sentences
now then asked whether she
still agrees with her prior call for
more police officers on the streets
which has been
really the big liability for kamala
harris
she doesn't directly answer as
politicians
often avoid doing instead she praises
black lives matter
as important also been a national
conversation about policing
and you know the name that you have
kamala top cop and the book that you
wrote 10 years ago
smart on crime where you conclude by
saying that you wanted to see more
police
on the street do you still feel that way
listen i think that there is no question
first of all when i
wrote that book um
we black lives matter did not exist
and i give full credit to the brilliance
of that movement in terms of what it has
done to advance
a conversation that needed to happen a
long time ago what black lives matter
has done as a movement
has been to be a counter force against
a very entrenched status quo around the
criminal justice system in america
and that's why i'm so excited about what
we can do
in terms of a new administration in the
white house okay
so kamala harris is sort of equivocating
she's saying black lives matter is good
she's saying well what i did before was
a while ago
you can't really explain it any
differently other than to say
i was attorney general at the time and i
was doing my job
this is this is standard politics and we
don't have to like it but again
it's not about whether you accept
kamala's answer
it's about the reality that these are
just normal people
who relate to the media normally who
relate to their families normally
who can complete a thought and that has
been so missing
for years in this country meanwhile
donald trump did not have a very good
weekend let's talk about that next
so donald trump had another humiliating
24 hours ending yesterday on the eve of
the republican national convention which
starts tonight
first of course trump golfed on saturday
as the coronavirus death toll
reached and surpassed 180 000 deaths
okay
we're a global embarrassment trump is
still golfing
don't need to spend a lot of time on
that sunday
trump announces a big press briefing
huge medical announcement
is going to be made big treatment news
about coronavirus
wow what could that be they schedule it
for 5 30
word leaks the announcement
is an fda emergency use authorization
for convalescent plasma what
that's been around as a coronavirus
trial treatment for months
tons of countries have been using
condolences how is how is that an
announcement that trump
what what that is what it was donald
trump
trying to take credit for something he
had nothing to do with
isn't news and isn't unique to the
united states and of course donald trump
continues to mispronounce the word
plasma as plasma
seven times in fact during this
announcement here is trump struggling
to even read what the announcement is
truly historic announcement in our
battle against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
the fda has issued an emergency
use authorization and
that's such a a powerful term emergency
use
authorization for a treatment known as
convalescent plasma
why can't somebody tell them it's plasma
is that like when you forget someone's
name
the second time you meet them and you
don't want to ask and then you've met
them 10 times
and now it's too late to ask and at this
point nobody wants to be the person to
go up to trump and say
sir as trump says people talk to him sir
it's
plasma not plasma then
more importantly substantively trump
exaggerated the benefit of plasma or
plasma
as it may be vaccine to save lives we're
removing unnecessary barriers and delays
not by cutting corners but by marshaling
the full power of the federal government
we provided 48 million dollars to fund
the mayo clinic study that tested the
efficacy of convalescent plasma for
patients with
the virus through this study over 100
000 americans have already enrolled
to receive this treatment and it has
proven to reduce
mortality by 35 percent
it's a tremendous number the fda mit
harvard and mount sinai hospital
have also found convalescent plasma to
be a very effective
method of fighting this horrible disease
based on the science and the data
the fda has made the independent
determination that the treatment is safe
and very effective now there are actual
questions about whether this emergency
use authorization
makes sense so to remind you this is a
trial treatment that's been around the
world for months there's nothing special
about the us
trying convalescent plasma there's a
good
uh thread on twitter which explains that
by giving an emergency authorization
you're making the treatment available to
way more people who aren't
actually that sick and who would likely
recover anyway
and could end up skewing the results and
exposing people to some pretty serious
side effects which can include
as a result of these plasma transfusions
lung injury
blood clots kidney issues etc so one of
the reasons you would maybe not
do an eua early is that when you keep
the treatment as part of randomly
controlled trials
you're actually carefully selecting
sicker patients
where you need something extra i have a
relative in argentina
who has coronavirus right now and they
would have been able to give her
convalescent plasma but they decided
she's not sick enough
and because there are side effects it we
don't want to just start giving it to
everybody at this point in time you
don't want to put people who aren't that
sick
at risk of dangerous side effects and
skew the results
by giving the treatment to people who
are less sick and likely to recover
anyway when you have an emergency use
authorization
people start asking for this it's more
available you start giving it to people
who aren't that sick
you end up with people with side effects
that didn't really need the treatment
and the treatment can appear more
effective than it is
all because trump wants something to
announce
okay so then trump takes just three
questions at a completely non-newsworthy
press briefing
one of the questions is from right wing
propaganda network oan
and then he walks off so quickly after
only three questions that you can tell
the other people on the stage are
surprised that that's it trump's leaving
take a look
very much great question on you
so that was part one of trump's late
afternoon
then trump was interviewed by this
horrible fox news host steve hilton
and it was just a train wreck yet again
this was another one of those interviews
meant to be easy
that just goes bad for trump trump has
been asked about
and has failed to answer what's your
biggest accomplishment from your first
term
trump in the past has given no answer
multiple times to that question
this time he had an answer and comically
it was worse than no answer at all trump
says his big accomplishments
are health care and transparency listen
to this
with healthcare we've done a great job
one of the other things i did i think
you just
one of the future is good transparency
i approve transparency that's bigger
than healthcare
the people i had working on and one of
them is like the all-time expert on
transparency highly respected
doctor he said sir if you get this
approved
this is bigger than health care
transparency where you can go
and negotiate and pick the best explain
why that helps people
because people will be able to negotiate
their prices
which right now they can't people will
be able to get better doctors
you know what's good for good hospitals
by the way hospitals are against it
because it makes them good good
hospitals and good doctors it's good for
good hospitals
it's the biggest thing maybe in health
care
of anything i'm doing so let's think
that through
health care trump tried twice i believe
in 2017
to get a plan passed that would replace
obamacare with something that will
lead to 24 to 32 million people
losing health care then what he did on
health care is strip the man
the mandate from obamacare which merely
makes obamacare function worse it
doesn't actually get rid of it
it just makes it function worse then he
says
transparency has been an accomplishment
i don't even have to get into that
i mean you know logan act hatch act
violations
lining his pockets and those of his
family and friends
not showing us his taxes not cooperating
with multiple investigations so
his accomplishments he says are health
care and transparency
out of this world and then again trump
says
he's been the best president for black
people in history
other than maybe abraham lincoln what do
you have to say to people who want
both law and order and racial justice
first of all i think i've done more
for the black community than any other
president other than perhaps abraham
lincoln and i think it's true with
criminal justice reform and opportunity
zones and all of the things i've done
a prison reform i mean what i've done is
more than anybody else
i don't know if it's being recognized at
all this little clip
those 23 seconds are everything that
trump is
i've done the most of anybody and nobody
gives me credit
that is the trump presidency in a
nutshell failing on everything
while claiming success and claiming
nobody's giving you credit
for that success another disastrous day
for trump by normal people standards
leading up to the rnc which starts
tonight it's gonna be wild
it's gonna be wild make sure you're
following me on twitter at deepakman i
will be tweeting during the rnc
and live streaming i hope to see you
then the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take thousands of popular nonfiction
books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in
15 minutes blinkist makes sure that
you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
today's new members of the day are
tiffany bowen and amanda scott
thanks to tiffany and amanda for the
membership subscriptions
also a big thank you to marsha carrera
who is today's
long-time sustaining member of the day
marsha's been a member for almost
five years grab yourselves a membership
at joinpackman.com this is super
interesting we've got the rnc starting
tonight in which overwhelmingly the case
for re-electing donald trump is going to
be made
by his own family members we're going to
be hearing how great donald trump is
from yes his own vice president but also
from his wife melania trump
his kids ivanka don jr eric and tiffany
and there will be some other speakers
including that couple from st
louis who pointed guns at protesters but
even trump's family isn't unanimously on
board with his reelection you already
know about marielle
trump's devastating book about him a few
weeks ago that's trump's niece
but there is now leaked audio where
donald trump's own sister marianne trump
barry
said that donald trump has no principles
that you can't trust
him and that he lies all the time now
this is not some random person
who doesn't know trump this is his
sister
let's listen to this devastating audio
and marianne trump barry
particularly aghast at the constant lies
from donald trump
it's goddamn tweet and the light oh my
god i'm talking too freely but you know
it is the change of stories a lack of
preparation the lying the holy
but he's appealing to the base what
they're doing with the kids
at the border i mean now right away
right wingers are focusing on
oh but these recordings were made
surreptitiously these these were secret
recordings
now that's true doesn't change anything
and notably
these were done surreptitiously but not
illegally because these recordings were
made in new york which is
a one-party consent state what that
means is that as long as one party to
the conversation
knows there's a recording being made
it's legal now we can debate the
morality of it
i'd argue that the moral imperative to
remove
trump is such that i'm not going to get
bent out of shape
by legal surreptitious recordings
maybe you disagree with me there that's
fine uh and now this is where it gets
super interesting remember the claim
that trump paid somebody to take his
sats for him
part of this audio includes trump's own
sister
saying she has knowledge of that take a
listen to this
i business but he was a tough kid right
he was a brat yeah that's what i mean i
don't mean
i said i mean to brad
new york city to try to get him into
college
he ended up in florida i've got him in
somehow
um before before i had any real catholic
roots
right but he i mean
i didn't get him in but buddy i know he
didn't get him to college
and he and he went to fordham for one
year
and then he got into university of
pennsylvania i guess he had
somebody to take his and take the exams
that's what i believe
so there's once again the claim in what
marianne trump barry
thought was a private conversation it
was recorded by marielle trump
saying trump paid someone to take his
sats
there are more clips let's listen to one
more where marianne barry
trump marian trump barry recalls a
conversation
where trump called to ask her hey did
you see me on fox news
and she said i don't really watch fox or
much tv
and trump was incredible he couldn't
believe wait what are you doing and she
explained that she reads books
take a look at this and he said did you
watch
fox news
i said no why not
i said i don't watch much television at
all
pause what do you do
i read pause
what do you read
books
what to me that that is just uh tim what
to me is just brilliant about these
recordings
are two things first of all trump's own
family
sees trump the way we do and what i mean
by that is
they know him privately and still react
in the same way that we react
to the public version of trump which
tells us
that privately trump really is that same
person that we see in public the
unempathetic
self-obsessed narcissistic maniac
it's the same guy now as far as these
recordings
uh changing anything as in terms of
election results
i don't think so you know donald trump's
base
um ignores anything that they don't like
they probably won't even hear about this
if they do
they'll ignore it and in reality there's
nothing here that we don't already
know and his base is so cult-like
that i don't think these recordings are
really going to do anything
in terms of hurting his election
re-election chances if you disagree with
me let me know
i i don't see it making any real big
impact
maybe the rnc will and that's what i
want to talk about next
so last thursday night joe biden gave
just a good
solid convention speech at the end of
the dnc and he's seen his favorability
go up by five points
now this is exactly why republicans said
on mond
last monday biden might get eight to ten
points
out of the dnc why did they do that
because never
does any presidential candidate get
eight to ten points out of the dnc
the reason republicans said it was so
that when biden gets
five or three or four they can say oh
he's really underperforming we expected
biden to get eight to ten points he only
got
three four or five now what's more
interesting to me
is typically conventions will boost
polling and favorability by three to
four
joe biden is actually exceeding that in
the latest
abc news ipsos poll which says biden's
favorability went from 40 to 45
in one week now that's still very low
in other words 40 is bad 45
is a little bit less bad but it's still
not a fantastic number you want to be
running on
if you want to unseat an incumbent
president
compare it to trump's favor ability
which is only 32 right now and pence is
even worse at 30. okay maybe it's not
a huge problem for joe biden so today
the rnc starts
we'll have to see what kind of a bump
donald trump gets out of it now
typically the way it goes is that both
candidates get bumps from their
respective conventions
but they're not permanent and some weeks
after the conventions numbers settle
back down
typically to where they were before the
conventions
started now what's interesting is that
biden's boost didn't come from doing
anything
spectacular or outrageous biden gave
a pretty milk toast coherent
normal speech we saw him relating to
people
like a normal person to his wife to his
family
that's a big contrast to donald trump
and we talked about that
a little bit earlier in the program
aside from the people who were expecting
biden to implode
uh being disappointed we basically saw a
preview
of what it would be like to have a
normal adult as president we wouldn't
have
wacky things happening every single day
we wouldn't have
all these scandals and some people in
reaction to this are emailing me and
they're saying david
this is such a low bar this is not
enough
this is nothing to praise biden about i
see it as
yeah it's it's feels better
to have an adult in charge who's not a
laughing stock
the bar being low is not an attack on
biden
it's a reminder of how low donald trump
has set the bar
and it's even scarier that 60 million or
more people
are likely to vote for keeping the bar
that low by voting to re-elect donald
trump in november so when people say
biden only seemed okay because the bar
is so low
that's not an attack on biden that's an
attack on the guy who set the bar so low
and that's donald trump now
what does seem less ideal is that
according to the same poll
only about 30 percent of americans even
watched any of the dnc
that's not great from from the
standpoint of enthusiasm
when you have a coronavirus pandemic
more people are staying home
the fact that fewer people watch this
than typically do is not great
however you can interpret that any
number of ways you could say the reason
fewer people watch the dnc
is they don't need to watch it to know
that they need to vote to remove donald
trump and vote for joe biden in november
it's one speculative interpretation the
point is
the lower viewership doesn't necessarily
tell us anything
my expectation is that the ratings for
the rnc
which starts tonight are going to be
much better but they're going to be
better
not because there's so many more
republicans enthusiastically waiting to
vote for donald trump compared to joe
biden
there are going to be a lot of people
hate watching the rnc
or watching it the way we look at a car
crash when we drive by
i wouldn't necessarily read too much
into it i expect
my live streams of the rnc and again my
audience is
way more left than it is right i expect
my live streams to do better
for the rnc than the dnc but it's not
because my audience is planning to vote
for trump
it's because my audience wants to see
the train wreck that is going to be
you know the couple from st louis who
pointed guns at protesters
speaking at a convention the question
ultimately is
once the rnc is all said and done what
does it do for trump
imagine a republican convention that
damages trump that'd be terrible more
likely
trump will get two to three points out
of it in the short run
that may be enough for him to get
reelected it may not it's just
very difficult for me to imagine being
on tv
four days in a row in prime time and
trump helping himself because he seems
to mess up at every opportunity but
conventions aside the refrain has to be
the constant reminder has to be trump
can steal this election
post office shenanigans combined with
foreign meddling
combined with other voter suppression
combined with taking credit for anything
coronavirus related that happens between
now and november i know
we look at maps and we say looks so easy
for biden he's just got to take a couple
of these states trump won and he's got
270.
you only need to suppress the modest
amount of votes in key states to flip
the results
and because there's such a huge urban
rural divide in this country
if you're a republican you know
you can hugely help your candidate by
just doing shenanigans in urban areas
you know that when you do that you were
disproportionately going to hit people
likely planning to vote for joe biden
and not donald trump they know this
okay trust me they know it last thing
the convention boosts being temporary
is fine but that still means
trump could be within two or three
points in the popular vote
and he won the electoral college in 2016
while being down more than two points in
the popular vote to hillary clinton
so what we can hope is different this
time around is that with early voting
the temporary boost may bleed over into
voting
and if joe biden got five and trump only
gets two or three
maybe early voting will be skewed to
biden and that will take away the power
that some october surprise would have
we're thinking out loud
all we can do is vote i hope you will i
know i plan to
uh continue following us on instagram
for more on this story we're on
instagram at david pakman show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 percent vote
soon 18.
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
so we've now learned of a child in iowa
who has died of coronavirus
complications and this was the first
death of a minor there during the
pandemic and meanwhile
schools are opening today in iowa
now there are schools in iowa that
decided
we're going to go remote for now or at
least they thought they decided it
because then the governor's
the governor of iowa came in and is
actually forcing some schools to open so
there's about three or four different
stories here
one is this is exactly why lots of
places try to make it illegal
or at least a violation of contracts for
teachers to go on strike
so that when the governor says jump
instead of saying
why are we jumping that doesn't make
sense they say how high and this is
exactly an example of that
it relates to collective bargaining it
relates to unions it relates to so many
different things on the labor side but
it's not our focus today the other side
of it
is really the craziness of of the
pandemic and the entire story of
opening and school openings and the like
and the really crazy thing about the
school starting fiasco
is that it's all becoming laughably
political and i want to be careful about
saying laughably because people's lives
are at stake here but what i mean is
it's obviously political
because we're now only talking about a
couple of months
it's just that they are months that are
crucial to donald trump's reelection and
possibly to the re-elections of
republicans in the house in the senate
gubernatorial republican reelections and
i'll explain
what i mean by that and be really
specific you have people on the right
like trump but many republican governors
although charlie baker here in
massachusetts has been good on this
republican senators you have all these
people saying open the schools now
open it for economic reasons open it for
mental health reasons you know being
closed leads to suicides and
uh mental health issues and isolation
and all of this stuff okay
their gambit is schools being open will
help them get reelected particularly
trump
the idea being the optics of schools
being open
is good politically it'll seem like
things are returning to normal
in advance of the november election and
there is a truth to it there i don't
deny that there's an economic reality
here
where many parents can't work or can't
work as much as they normally would
if their kids aren't in school because
they're essentially counting on school
for child care they are in jobs thanks
to our economy
that don't pay enough for them to be
able to say okay i'll pay for child care
and then go to work the numbers don't
make sense so
i'm completely sensitive to that and
these are real issues
i'm not brushing off the issue of
opening schools
as something that we shouldn't even
consider in some places
there are counties that have almost no
cases
and in particular there are these sort
of semi-rural
schools where you might have like seven
through 12
might have 150 kids right 25 kids per
class
you can do that relatively safely and
i'm not against
doing that the problem is that's not the
case
in a variety of places that are opening
where we've
instantly seen cases spread quarantine
start etc
and again it's almost september at this
point we're talking about
one semester had we done it's always too
little too late
had we done a full coordinated shutdown
in the spring
two months maybe three full mass
compliance we would look like many
countries which now are doing well
and we wouldn't be having this
conversation to the degree that we are
having it would be clear
there's a bunch of schools that can open
but now
everything has to stay open things the
guidelines are ignored schools must open
and we're in a position
where for political reasons donald trump
and others want to force schools open
and we saw what happened we looked at
georgia we looked at missouri
we're looking at iowa indiana everywhere
kids and teachers start getting sick
entire classes
have to be quarantined for weeks you're
essentially ending up sending a whole
bunch of people home anyway
it would be far more logical although
maybe not politically beneficial
to say let's do the semester remote
we're not saying no
school we're not saying no school for a
long time if things go well
we are hopefully hopefully just a couple
of months from some vaccine approval
optimistically
which by the end of the year some more
significant number of people will be
able to start getting
and in the spring semester things will
start to normalize
with it will still take time but right
now
the debate is over just a few months and
what is the real obstacle for many
parents it's the money piece
other countries have said let's be safe
and let's
really send people money and take care
of people
the long run benefit suggests it's
warranted
in the u.s it took months to get one
twelve hundred dollar payment
to people who knows if and when the next
one is going to come
and that creates this problem it's the
same with
the desire for many on the right to cut
the
unemployment benefits if you do that
you're going to force people back to
work not safely necessarily
but it will create a semblance of
normalcy so
they will frame it as the left wants
everything closed forever
the left wants everything closed until
november 4th
just to hurt trump right one of these
two it's almost september we're talking
about like three months now just do
school from home we'll get to winter
break and then hopefully by then
some portion of the population will
start to be vaccinated
we'll be starting to get beyond the
halfway point of flu season
we're all going to be better off without
having to reshut down because things
explode
that's disastrous economically flu
season coming
i got my flu shot friday glad to have it
dr fauci recently said this won't go on
forever
but we have to be safe until we get to
the other side and now
iowa which opens schools today with the
first confirmed
child coronavirus death
there is a new poll about the virus
which shows that
republicans democrats and independents
are really living in alternate
moral realities when it comes to
coronavirus deaths now notice that i'm
not saying
alternate realities in this case
everybody was presented with the fact
that at the time 176 000 people had died
of coronavirus the poll was done a few
days ago
we're now close to 181 000 coronavirus
deaths but at the time
republicans democrats and independents
were told 176 000 people
have died of coronavirus okay presented
with that fact
do you believe that is an acceptable
amount of death
most republicans believe it is of course
democrats and independents don't think
176
000 deaths is acceptable so this is a
cbs news
yougov poll of 2200 registered voters
margin of error of 2.4 and it found that
57 of republicans believe
176 000 coronavirus deaths is
acceptable more than half of republicans
believe that's an acceptable death toll
only 10 percent of democrats believe 176
000 deaths is acceptable
and only 33 percent of independents do
by a two to one margin
independents believe the death toll is
unacceptable
now first of all it's the hypocrisy
a ton of these same republicans who say
176 000 coronavirus deaths are
acceptable
thought barack obama needed to resign
because
two people died of ebola in the united
states there's always a hypocrisy angle
let's not make that the focus today
secondly
there's a morality component here is it
possible
that the reason republicans think the
deaths are acceptable
is that early on the deaths were mostly
in blue states
with direct aviation links to china
and the other countries in europe that
were seated with the virus
early could it be that republicans are
okay with deaths
as long as they're mostly democratic
voters i don't know the answer to that
but it's certainly possible but the
really interesting thing statistically
is that you don't have an even partisan
divide and that could be a factor in
november and i want to be really clear
about explaining this
we always expect that all else being
equal
if you have a purely partisan divide in
any issue
you would expect for example that
independence would be roughly 50 50
split on an issue
and you would expect that the democrat
republican
uh imbalance would be equal this isn't
super clear the way i'm explaining it so
let me give you an example
you would expect that if republicans
support
something 70 30 democrats
would oppose it 70 30 all else being
equal meaning if there isn't some other
factor to consider now there's always
some other factor to consider right so
when you look at abortion
you don't have approval for abortion in
most cases among democrats
equal to disapproval among republicans
there's religious components
there's other factors that go into it so
right now the country is
more in favor of abortion than they've
ever been and part of it is you don't
have an
even partisan divide yes republicans are
more against abortion than democrats
but it's not to the same degree okay
here with this question on the
acceptability of coronavirus deaths
the partisan divide is very unequal if
we look at the numbers again you'll see
that
even among republicans 43 percent think
the death toll is unacceptable
it is unbalanced with the democratic
number
showing us that this issue is stronger
than partisanship
it's still hugely partisan but even
republicans 43 of them are putting aside
partisanship and saying
the death toll is not acceptable despite
it being
our guy trump who oversaw it it's not
acceptable and then of course when you
look at independents
who are not 50 50 split but by a two to
one margin
say this is not okay this could be a
difference maker
in november coronavirus is polling as a
top
issue for voting in november and even
among republicans 43 percent say the
results are unacceptable if
some of those republicans vote biden if
some of them
say i'm not going to vote biden but i'm
going to stay home it could be enough to
push trump out of office now of course
on the other side we've got voter
suppression
the postal service foreign meddling all
of this stuff
so that's why we need to bring out
enforce
these folks who already democrats by a
90 to 10 margin
think the coronavirus handling is
unacceptable we've got to make sure
that they vote last thing how can
republicans call themselves pro-life
and be the group that by the largest
margin believes 176 000 deaths are
acceptable
just something to think about the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about them
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the president of the united states has
had a tweet flagged by twitter
because it is encouraging people not to
vote by telling them things that are not
true
about coronavirus this is incredible the
the sitting president of the united
states is violating the terms of service
of a social media platform not for
something unrelated to his election
but because he is spreading
disinformation about his
own upcoming re-election donald trump
tweeted quote
so now the democrats are using mail drop
boxes which are a voter security
disaster now
of course these are municipalities using
the boxes it's not
democrats trump goes on to say among
other things they make it possible for
for a person to vote multiple times also
who controls them
are they placed in republican or
democrat areas
they are not covid sanitized a big
fraud and rightly twitter put the
message up on the tweet which says
this tweet violated the twitter rules
about civic and election
integrity so there are really two parts
here
the first is donald trump is continuing
to say that vote by mail absentee drop
boxes
none of it is secure this is not true
trump is saying that without evidence
i'm sure you know that by now
part two of this is this new idea of
playing on people's fears of coronavirus
by saying
you know the drop boxes for the ballots
they're not
covid sanitized and this is a clear
attempt to dissuade biden voters
how do we know that because biden voters
we know
are taking coronavirus more seriously
than our trump voters
biden voters are more likely to be
planning to vote by mail
to avoid maybe catching coronavirus at a
polling place
biden voters are more likely to wear
masks when they go outside
so we know that if you start spreading
the idea
the ballot dropbox might give you the
virus
you are going to disproportionately hit
biden voters
but it could backfire if democrats
are more likely not to believe what
trump says
and trump voters are more likely to
believe what donald trump says
it's conceivable that this idea of
saying you know you could get
coronavirus from the dropbox
it might end up keeping his own voters
at home i
don't think in the end it will have a
hugely disproportionate
impact one way or the other but twitter
is completely correct to flag his tweet
and to put a warning on it donald trump
is terrified
that people are going to come out and
vote in huge numbers and not for him but
for the other guy
and in fact the entire republican party
is terrified of that i expect
that as the election gets closer trump
is going to be going even crazier and
pulling out all the stops
everything will be on the table we have
to make sure it backfires
we have to keep publicizing that he's
doing this because
there's one thing we know people will be
more determined to vote
the more they realize trump doesn't want
them to people are just like that by
nature
the post office was a turning point for
many americans
sending troops into cities was a turning
point for many americans
this is a cult it's a dangerous one and
a lot of people understandably would
crawl
over broken glass to vote in november
the president of the united states is
trying to suppress the vote
obviously he should have long ago been
banned from twitter
regularly bullying people breaking just
about every term and condition they have
but this is bigger than twitter mail-in
ballots are bad ballot drop boxes could
be infected with coronavirus
we have to stop it we have to stop it
and uh
you listen let's skip it you know what
you have to do
we have now learned that jared kushner
donald trump's son-in-law made a deal
with russia
for ventilators during the coronavirus
crisis in order to be able to say hey
we've gotten ventilators we got
ventilators
it turns out every single ventilator we
got from russia
was faulty according to a new report
every aspect of this story is crazy so
first of all
it's crazy that jared kushner donald
trump's son-in-law
is working in the administration it's
insane for reasons of nepotism
it's insane for reasons of kushner's
incompetence then you might remember
that at some point
in maybe it was april or may i don't
know they trotted out jared kushner to
do a coronavirus press briefing and it
went horribly wrong we never saw him
again
this was the briefing where kushner
dropped this kafka-esque line of
you know the ventilator supply is our
supply it's not the state supply which
is like you know what we discussed that
in detail at the time it was
indecipherable evil genius
and we never saw him again at the press
briefings but even more importantly
some of the things that kushner was
doing uh
were laughably counterproductive so for
example
kushner organized getting a shipment of
ventilators from russia to the u.s in
late march
they were faulty they didn't work andrew
cuomo got some of them
other officials got them and they
started seeing supplies come in from
russia
and they they were wondering why are we
getting russian supplies
and the ventilators were faulty jared
kushner was able to hurry up the
delivery of
faulty ventilators because he has a
personal relationship
with the ceo of a russian sovereign
wealth fund
currently sanctioned by the united
states so
another insane detail kushner got us
faulty ventilators more quickly
by doing business with a russian dude
who's currently under sanctioned by the
united states
every aspect of this is insane then they
gave the ventilators to officials in new
york and new jersey
including andrew cuomo the official said
these don't work and
initially they said well it's just that
there's a voltage issue
because these are russian ventilators
once we fix the voltage
voltage issue it'll be fine turns out
that wasn't true the
ventilators were completely faulty and
this would be a comedy of errors if
people's lives
weren't depending on it the shipment
from russia
listen to this insanity the shipment
from russia came with other supplies
that weren't even hospital supplies like
for example
trump talks about getting gloves we're
talking about surgical gloves
medical grade gloves russia sent us
household cleaning gloves
understand that okay just household
cleaning gloves
and russia build the us six hundred
thousand dollars for those gloves
in the middle of a hundred year pandemic
for which donald trump was completely
unprepared he starts buying
faulty incorrect medical supplies
from russia now there are also reports
of more than 50 million dollars worth of
contaminated
coronavirus tests from the united arab
emirates
so the reason we elected this guy was
supposedly that a businessman
would do really well running the country
now trump is a failed businessman okay
but this is how it all works and quite
frankly this is all seeming more like
money laundering than anything else
now back to the russian ventilators for
a second
russia sent us 45 faulty ventilators
around april 1 which we paid for
we later heard news that the trump
administration
was sending putin 200 of our ventilators
as part of a foreign aid like we just
gave them to him so think about that
we buy 50 ventilators or 45 ventilators
from russia which are faulty
and then we give them 200 of our
ventilators which work well
this is how a businessman runs the
country is it money laundering is it
embezzlement and this is just one story
among hundreds like this
in this administration we may never know
the full reality of it and you know what
if we get rid of them i don't care if we
never know the full reality of every
single one of these stories
we have a voicemail number which is 2192
david p
here's a caller who is not in favor of
joe biden
listen to what he has to say yeah i'm
watching here for the first time
i just want you to know that you call
yourself
well i'm looking at free speech tv
the killed by the lucky cousin
of the united states you'll be lucky to
be
free speech tv
i want you to think about that
he is pretty much he is pretty much to
the left wing of that
party which is not even a party anymore
this radical extremist leftist
thanks a lot of pacman yeah listen um
biden's not the authoritarian it's trump
who's been hostile to a free press it's
trump who's been hostile to media it's
trump who's kicked people out of the
press briefing room
it's trump who calls media fake news and
the enemy of the people
joe biden you can say a lot of negative
things about joe biden
and we've said many of them joe biden is
not an authoritarian
joe biden clearly much like barack obama
respects and understands the role
of a free and independent press and this
is how things go backwards
trump is one of the most authoritarian
and hostile to media presidents we've
had in a long time
and people are calling me saying media
and free speech are in trouble
if biden wins come on guys you're living
in a fantasy world
on today's bonus show i am going to tell
the story
of firefighters visiting my house at 4
00 a.m
this weekend okay why were they at my
house at 4 am this weekend
i'll tell you on the bonus show make
sure to sign up at joinpakman.com or by
becoming a patron
at patreon.com david pakmanship
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blinkist the app that
lets you
read or listen to an entire non-fiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
for free
and save 25 percent off of a
subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video